[Music]
scientists have discovered many planets
similar to earth beyond our solar system
these exoplanets can be up to 10 times
larger than earth which might be ideal
for
our growing population but with
more mass comes more gravity
and despite having more space
for life we'd be heavily affected
in many ways on a super earth
what would happen if we evolved on a
bigger planet
what would life be like on a super earth
what are the risks and
could we survive as a species
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we
lived or evolved on a super earth
imagine growing up on gj180d
a neptune-like exoplanet seven and a
half times the mass of our earth
this super earth is located in the
habitable zone
orbiting a red dwarf star at a safe
distance
one year on gj180d lasts a mere
106 days less than one third of a year
on earth
your summers may be a little shorter on
gj180d
but a week's vacation would stretch a
whole lot further than it would on earth
to live on a super earth would require
super strength
if earth were 10 times larger gravity
would be
10 times stronger this is based on the
formula of
surface area equals mass divided by
radius
squared a short jog on a super earth
would feel like running a marathon the
stress on our muscles and bones
would increase by a factor of 10.
at the very least you could cut down on
your reps when you work out
technically our skeletons can withstand
a force of
more than 90 times that of earth's
gravity but
only when standing still with much more
force
pulling us down our organs would shift
and we'd likely develop some serious
health issues
and an unavoidable punch maybe a little
super earth yoga
might help our atmosphere here on earth
is held together by gravity at sea level
atmospheric pressure is around one
atmospheric unit
but at higher altitudes like the peak of
mount everest
the pressure is much lower approximately
0.33 atmospheric units because
it's further from the earth's core we
don't notice this pressure very much but
the air we breathe would feel much
heavier
on a super earth just as air pressure
changes with gravity
our water would also be affected
with more air pressure water would take
longer to boil
and freeze this is because it would
require
more energy for water molecules to
evaporate
or solidify into a heavier atmosphere
prepare to wait a lot longer for your
instant noodles
although we might be able to survive in
these heavier conditions
the gravity of this super earth
situation
is much more dangerous than you might
think
earth's gravity helps keep our magnetic
field intact
the movement of liquid iron in our outer
core generates this magnetic field which
protects us from harmful solar radiation
on a super earth higher gravitational
pressure might cause a
solid inner core no liquid movement of
iron would mean
no magnetic shield and we'd be at risk
of severe
radiation exposure we may need to wear
protective suits
or build sheltered walkways just to be
outside
and this solar radiation could knock out
any power grids meaning
we'd have to find new ways of
transferring electricity
and with a drastically weakened ozone
layer
our risk of getting certain
environmental cancers would
seriously increase but that isn't even
the biggest problem
with a greater gravitational pull we'd
be attracting more
unwanted objects from space the
likelihood of meteors and asteroids
striking us would be
much higher take jupiter for example
with two and a half times earth's
gravity
it gets hit up to 60 times a year by
objects ranging anywhere from
5 to 20 meters in diameter
in 2009 it was struck by a whopping
500 meter asteroid the size of a giant
asteroid hitting a super earth
would be important but also where might
it land
66 million years ago an asteroid
collided with earth in a carbon rich
area
causing organic material in rocks to be
heated
and ejected into the atmosphere forming
soot in the stratosphere
this triggered drastic climate cooling
which led to the mass extinction of
dinosaurs
as a result mammals evolved
if this asteroid had landed somewhere
else
maybe there could still be dinosaurs
roaming around today
a similar global annihilation is very
probable on a super earth
for humans to survive and evolve on a
planet like this
we would have to be very lucky so
what if we needed to leave this super
earth to avoid a disaster
well our space program would need a much
bigger budget
more gravity to contend with would mean
a lot more fuel to get anywhere
for a rocket carrying a payload of over
40 000 kilograms
similar to the one used on the apollo
moon mission
the fuel required would cause the rocket
to weigh
over 360 million kilograms
this would be like trying to launch the
empire state building
one polish mathematician suggested
another solution
nuclear pulse propulsion
for this an unmanned probe carrying
dozens to
several hundred nuclear bombs would fly
alongside a rocket
detonating these bombs at close
intervals would help push the rocket
upward
this is pretty risky though especially
if the probe
misfires in our direction to put it
simply
if we lived on a super earth we might be
stuck there for a while
we'd probably be better off just
exploring space with telescopes from the
super earth's surface
if you want to dive deeper into what
life might be like for the human
race on a super earth check out our what
if discussed episode on
this exact topic we sat down with
astrophysicist
jack madden of cornell university who
filled us in
on all the details of exoplanets and
super earths